yao jian mesdames et messieurs
participants à la conférence
s'il vous plaît n'oubliez pas vos
masques
ceux qui n'ont pas de décodeur pour
écouter la traduction et s'il vous plaît
vous pouvez vous munir des écouteurs de
traduction simultanée merci
avec un passif
là ça va
demain
m
non
[Musique]
ap
la rue
ça veut l'ouvrir
l'école
germain
parent
voilà
de même
les valeurs
je
nos jeunes
janot
par semaine
on
la lame sa douleur
par exemple
fait
pourquoi nous
voilà
bonjour permettez-moi de vrir notre
conférence consacrée au retour des
réfugiés
mesdames et messieurs au nom du comité
d'organisation de notre conférence
internationale consacrée au retour des
réfugiés
je vous salue ici à damas damas c'est le
minaret de la paix et l'étoile est
insolente dans la lumière éternelle
aujourd'hui essaie de dissimuler les
forces de la haine et des hostilités
mais l'amour des syriens envers leur
patrie a vaincu cette haine et cette
lumière de dieu cette lumière divine
nous aide
aujourd'hui nous avons restauré la paix
et la stabilité en syrie
trois lettres de notre alphabet arabe al
alam et imeem 1 ce qui signifie les
souffrances de nos frères de nos
concitoyens qu'ils étaient obligés de
fuir leur ville et le village à la
recherche d'une vie plus stable et plus
sécurisé et le deuxième manche c'est le
mot espoir en arabe c'est la nostalgie
pour sa maison et ce désir d'être de
retour chez soi c'est le désir
d'embrasser son propre et justement
notre conférence est consacrée à la
création des conditions pour le retour
des réfugiés cela va nécessiter tous nos
efforts et en partant de cette idée
nous avons invité tous les pays du monde
à participer à cette conférence
malgré les contradictions qui existent
tout en surmontant tout le malheur que
nous avons survécu
le malheur qui que tous les syriens
partout dans le jeu tous les syriens
partout dans le monde nous avons espéré
que notre invitation a été soit acceptée
mais suite à des ambitions et frais
n'est pas tout le pays ont répondu à
notre invitation et pourtant c'est un
très bon prétexte pour garantir le
retour de ces réfugiés
la position des pays qui ont refusé de
participer à cette conférence
c'est une sorte d'hypocrisie
quand il parle des droits de l'homme ils
versent des larmes de crocodile mais il
utilise les souffrances des réfugiés
pour atteindre leurs propres intérêts
politiques
encore une fois mesdames et messieurs je
salue tous les participants à la
conférence
je vous souhaite un très bon travail un
très bon séjour à damas un travail
fructueux
parce que aujourd'hui nos adressons le
message d'espoir à tous les syriens qui
voudraient retourner dans leur propre
pays
notre coeur est au vert pour tous les
contacts comptes après eux compatriote
pardon le problème des réfugiés c'est
une page noire de notre histoire
mesdames et messieurs je vous propose de
visionner une vidéo qui parle des
souffrances des réfugiés en syrie
[Musique]
ce week end des états entiers ont
financé les forces qui ont attaqué la
série ils ont inventé des mensonges et
et y avait pas un seul migrants qui
n'étaient pas concernés par ces
souffrances
un jour ou l'autre
beaucoup de syriens ont été obligés de
fuir leurs maisons
il ne portait avec eux que quelques
affaires une casserole un vêtement une
couverture
il avait faim ils n'avaient pas d'eau il
avait soif mais surtout il avait très
peur ils ne comprenaient pas ce qui se
passe parce que au nord et au sud
c'était l'enfer et à ce moment critique
c'était vraiment une catastrophe et il
fallait faire quelque chose et chercher
de l'eau même si cette eau était très
sale
il avait toujours faim le malheur était
à au rendez vous c'était des souffrances
qui était dans les intérêts de ceux pour
qui ne pensent qu'aux commerces dans les
camps des réfugiés il n'y aurait pas
d'électricité il n'y avait pas de
confort moderne et dans leur âme
c'était du vide
nous vivons dans ce camp comme des
animaux notre vie est très dure
l'eau et la nourriture ne sont pas
terribles
nous ne savons pas ce que nous pouvons
faire nous voulons revenir en syrie oui
ils étaient chassés de leurs maisons
là où il est il est né il aimait
beaucoup dieu et il ne comprenait pas
comment c'est possible
il ne comprenait pas le sens de ces
événements mais il avait toujours
l'espoir et cet espoir vivait au jour un
des petites filles se prostituent et les
hommes étaient traités comme des poupées
des centaines de millions de dollars ont
été débloqués pour aider les réfugiés
mais cet argent n'arrivait pas vers une
bonne destination
le sultan rêver des esclaves des
esclaves qui vivaient dans ces camps
il y avait des gens qui m'ont amené
ils m'ont donné des médicaments des
comprimés
j'ai pris ces comprimés
j'avais des vertiges dans deux jours
deux jours après je me suis retrouvé
dans un temps avec plusieurs hommes qui
m'ont violée
c'était exploitation des hommes
n'avaient pas de fin l'europe comprend
très bien ce que faire d'un gant elle
comprend très bien que la seule solution
c'est le retour à en syrie puisque pour
nos la patrie c'est ce qu'il ya de plus
précieux
vivre dans un autre pays c'est très dur
pour moi le plus précieux c'est la
patrie et dieu grâce aux dieux
notre pays est le meilleur pays au monde
no vous remercions pour votre accueil
dieu merci nous sommes de retour dans
notre propre pays dans nos familles nos
allons à l'école oui la terre natale
c'est ce qu'il ya de mieux vivre à
l'étranger c'est une humiliation
j'ai vécu dans un autre pays
mais je rêvais de mon propre pays je
veux que tout le monde revienne en syrie
puisque c'est notre sol natal
c'est ce qu'il ya de plus précieux
[Musique]
je pouvais vivre des années dans un
autre pays
mais je rêve toujours de revenir puisque
notre pays c'est le meilleur pays au
monde
oui moi aussi je peux vivre dans notre
pays avec un rêve de retour sains y'a
pas d'autres pays qui est meilleur je
suis de retour à mon propre école
il y as délais sont des courants
j'ai planté des arbres tout va bien chez
moi il ya des sourires
il ya des visages heureux c'est pas un
rêve c'est une joie sincère
la joie des gens qui reviennent sur
leurs propres terres le camp al rock
band c'est le camp qui est contrôlé par
les groupements de d'ailleurs les
groupements qui ont été formés par les
forces d'occupation américain des
centaines des gens qui sont retenus dans
ce car nous sommes arrivés dans ce car
dans ce camp à roques banner contrôlés
par des personnes armées
dieu merci nous sommes de retour chez
nous dieu merci l'état nohad à tout va
bien
dans ce camp d'agban il n'y a pas
d'école il n'y a pas de cours mais c'est
la fin de nos souffrances
comment échapper de ces trafiquants
d'esclaves d'esclaves
nous nous adressons à la communauté
internationale damas c'est leur propre
ville
la ville natale le drapeau syrien c'est
notre drapeau
nous étions chassé par d'alléchants de
nos propres terres tandis que le franc a
nostra et d'autres groupements coopère
avec des shs et la syrie c'est notre
mère qui souffre parce que son fils
souffre un as et de souffrance
s'il vous plaît revenez en syrie nous
allons partager notre pain nous allons
vivre ensemble à cette souffrance la
patrie vos m
nous voulons la paix nous voulons que
nos familles soit avec nos
[Musique]
le retour tant attendu
je vends de la parole au président de la
république arabe syrienne bachar
el-assad
mesdames et messieurs les représentants
des pays participants à cette conférence
chers invités je vous salue à damas sur
le sol syrien
bienvenue en syrie qui a traversé des
années de guerre et qui a été affaiblie
par des blessures suite à des violences
et les crimes du terrorisme mais nous
ressentons une joie suite à la rencontre
aux gens honnêtes nous gardons cet
espoir dans nos coeurs
avant tout je voudrais exprimer leurs
remerciements à nos amis russes
pour l'heure c'est fort pour leur
travail de soutien et l'organisation de
cette conférence internationale à je
remercie également nos amis iraniens
pour leurs efforts et pour le soutien
réel qui a contribué à faciliter les
souffrances de la guerre alléger ses
souffrances
je crois que cette conférence va être
couronnée de succès nous allons parler
du retour des réfugiés syriens et des
familles séparées
malgré les difficultés économiques nous
avons créé les conditions de retour
certains pays ont été accueillis non
réfugiés un partant des principes
d'humanisme et du moral moral mais il ya
d'autres pays en occident et dans notre
région qui se sont qu'on parte comporter
de manière et 2 puisque pour eux les
intérêts politiques sont plus important
c'est la source de corruption
ils sont ignorés les principes de
solidarité
au lieu de créer des conditions propices
pour le retour de nos réfugiés
ces pays ont fait une pression sur ces
déjà déplacées et empêchent leur retour
en syrie
il ya aussi des forces qui essaie
d'implanter le terrorisme en syrie mais
il s'agit des millions de vies alors
nous nous ferons tout notre possible
pour et créer des conditions de retour
des réfugiés en syrie et j'espère que
cette conférence va contribuer à la
création de ces conditions pour le monde
entier le problème de réfugiés c'est un
problème d'ordre humanitaire pour nos
s'est pas uniquement le problème
humanitaire
c'est un problème de valeurs nationales
nous avons réussi déjà à garantir le
retour des dizaines de milliers de
réfugiés
nous garantissons le retour à chaque
personne qui voudrait revenir en syrie
et qui voudraient travailler dans le
cadre de la reconstruction de notre pays
non nous avons des barrières économiques
suite à des sanctions imposées par le
régime américain
mais toutes les institutions publiques
syriennes travail sur la reconstruction
du pays
ils combattent le terrorisme
il est gay construisent des conditions
pour une vie décente
ceux qui hésitent encore un devrait
comprendre que
les scieries les attentes aujourd'hui
plus que jamais il y à un grand nombre
de réfugiés qui voudraient revenir et je
voudrais m'adresser au régime à qui
empêchent le retour de nos concitoyens
nous ferons tout notre possible pour
garantir leur retour
malgré toutes les difficultés
la syrie qui est un pays ancien qui a
une tradition historique attend nos
concitoyens ce phénomène de réfugiés
nous lever vos depuis des années malgré
des difficultés que nous éprouvons
malgré les sanctions du régime américain
malgré les problèmes créés par des pays
voisins le cette diffusion du terrorisme
c'était une ville à une voix ils ont
emprunté depuis 2006 il finance
l'organisation terroriste état islamique
d'autres groupements armés comme le
franc al nostra qui massacrait des gens
innocents qui détruisait
l'infrastructure qui paralysé le service
et tous les services
et il y avait un moment où on commençait
à perdre l'espoir mais cet état
terroriste
d'ailleurs été vécue il s'agit de la
libération des grands territoires
syriens
grâce à l'abnégation de nos forces
armées
bien sûr nous faisons face aux problèmes
compliqués il ya des millions de
réfugiés qui voudraient revenir mais
notre offre infrastructure a beaucoup
souffert dès aujourd'hui le terrorisme
déstabilise la situation dans notre pays
tant de nombreux nombreuses régions de
notre pays nous avons quand même réussi
à progresser dans cette voie de
reconstruction tout en continuant la
guerre contre le terrorisme
non c'est vite on des centaines de
réfugiés nous avons créé un cadre
normatif comme par exemple l'ajournement
du service militaire donnant pour les
jeunes sans nous avons besoin des
travailleurs pour reconstruire le
ravitaillement en eau le réseau routier
pour que ceux qui reviennent sains soit
capable de vivre dans des conditions
décentes
mesdames et messieurs je suis certain
que notre conférence est capable de
créer des conditions pour le travail
international sur le retour des réfugiés
suite à la guerre chaque maison syrienne
a sauvé a souffert des gens honnêtes
comprennent ce qui se passe en syrie
il y a une grande blessure qui n'est pas
encore guéri et nous allons y travailler
je souhaite beaucoup de succès à votre
conférence
je vous souhaite de travailler sur le
retour des réfugiés en syrie
encore une fois merci d'être venus soyez
en paix
maintenant je dans la parole à alexandre
l'apprenti est représentant spécial du
président russe pour la syrie qui va
présentent-elles du secours en nombre du
ministre russe des affaires étrangères
sergueï lavrov
puis à d'autres participants
représentant de l'iran la chine le liban
puis au colonel général mais quel
musicien chef de l'état-major
interministériel de coordination de la
fédération de russie
le président de la république arabe
syrienne mesdames messieurs permettez
moi de vous présenter le discours de
bienvenue adressé aux participants à la
conférence internationale sur le retour
des réfugiés syriens et des personnes
déplacées à l'intérieur du pays au nom
du ministre russe des affaires
étrangères sergueï lavrov
mesdames messieurs participants à la
conférence
nous sommes reconnaissants aux
représentants des états des
organisations internationales qui se
sont réunis dans cette salle et qui sont
intéressés d'un le sort du peuple syrien
et qui doit lutter contre le terrorisme
aujourd'hui on a réussi à rétablir la
paix dans la plupart du pays dans les
zones libérées des terroristes on a
commencé des travaux pour reconstruire
la vie normale une des conditions
importantes et le respect de la
souveraineté de l'indépendance de
l'unité de l'intégrité territoriale de
ce billet en conformité avec la
résolution avant de 54 des nations-unies
et nous estimons que le retour des
réfugiés et des personnes déplacées est
une condition essentielle
il faut réunir les conditions pour la
vie digne et cela nécessite la
participation de l'ensemble de la
communauté internationale
la russie soutient la syrie nous
déployons nos efforts pour inviter le
plus grand nombre de pays d'organisation
a participé à ce travail de
reconstruction des objets
d'infrastructures en syrie nous avons
aidé nos amis syriens à organiser la
présente conférence on doit constater
que malheureusement tous ne
s'intéressent pas ne sommes pas
intéressés à rétablir les normes à la
syrie après de nombreuses tentatives de
tenir l'état est déployée par les
terroristes a maintenant ils utilisent
les méthodes économiques
je lise les mesures et légitime
unilatérale à bloc
l'aide extérieure créer des obstacles
pour prévenir le retour des réfugiés et
personnes déplacées sur le sol syrien
on estime que ces mesures sont
inhumaines et non constructive les
approches de ce qui impose les
conditions politiques
dans ce contexte il faut mentionner le
refus dans nombre de pays tels que les
états unis de participer à ce forum
humanitaire qui est organisée je le
répète en conformité avec la résolution
vendre 54 du conseil de sécurité des
nations unies ils essaient de d'empêcher
organisé cette réunion nous estimant que
c'est une approche qui témoigne de deux
poids deux mesures qui marque leur
intérêt politique
cette position typiques pour les états
qui ont participé à la tees mans de
cette tragédie syrienne et qui
soutiennent les forces telles que les
forces terroristes
ils sont responsables pour cette presse
j'ai dit des millions de syriens qui ont
dû quitter leur pays
cher participants à la conférence
je vous souhaite un travail fructueux je
suis convaincu qu'ensemble nous pouvons
donner un nouvel élan au rétablissement
de la vie normale en syrie il est
important que les syriens puissent
revenir regagner leurs foyers
sergueï lavrov merci
le second de messieurs le ministre des
affaires étrangères charbel werber
mesdames messieurs
monsieur walid al-mouallem tout d'abord
je tiens à remercier les organisateurs
de la conférence internationale sur le
retour des réfugiés syriens
j'espère que cette conférence c'est que
les discussions aient le travail de ces
conférences sur un constructif la
résolution de la crise des réfugiés
syriens ainsi que de la crise
humanitaire et qui est la plus grande
crise depuis la fin de la seconde guerre
mondiale est essentielle et je remercie
la fédération de russie qui déploie ses
efforts pour résoudre la crise syrienne
qui est soutien la coopération entre
toutes les parties qui soutient
l'initiative sur le retour des réfugiés
syriens
cette initiative a été proposée le 16
juin 2018 et la conférence d'aujourd'hui
est organisée pour mettre un oeuvre à
cette initiative le liban espère que
neuf ans après le début de ces
souffrances nos frères syriens vont
revenir en série à rétablir la paix
l'ensemble des réfugiés vont regagner
leurs foyers vont rétablir leur répit
d'autant plus que la plus grande partie
du pays a déjà été libéré il est
important de réunir les conditions
à l'intérieur du puits et le plus grand
obstacle au règlement de la crise
syrienne reste l'absence de la volonté
politique de la part de la communauté
internationale
la volonté réelle de mettre fin à cette
question là le problème des personnes
déplacées à l'intérieur du pays n'est
pas prise en compte par les pires qui
sont parties au conflit dans la région
tout cela a provoqué la politisation et
le mépris des souffrances des gens ainsi
que des dégâts pour des pays qui ont
acquis ces réfugiés
ce qui constitue une catastrophe
économique pour le liban depuis le début
de la guerre syrienne
dès que l'ensemble des routes ont été
fermées notre pays a fait face à ses
cette situation qui a épuisé non
possibilités économiques plus d'un
million de réfugiés syriens ont
constitué une grande pression économique
pour nous ce qui en plus sur la
situation intérieure au liban et dans la
région
nous accueillons plus de cinq cent mille
réfugiés palestiniens et cela depuis 70
ans
cela représente une menace pour la
stabilité au liban
c'est une menace pour la sécurité
de nettoyant un autre économie après
l'explosion dans le corps de beyrouth la
situation s'est aggravée
nous devons déployer plus d'efforts que
jamais il faut se focaliser sur un
réseau sécurisé de réfugiés dans leur
pays la syrie surtout dans les zones qui
sont déjà stable et sécurisé et il ne
faut pas relier ce retour à la
résolution finale de la crise syrienne
il faut encourager le retour des
réfugiés en syrie en conformité avec la
déclaration finale du sommet arabe qu'a
eu lieu le 20 janvier 2019
en s'appuyant sur ces principes le liban
demande à la communauté internationale
de soutenir le gouvernement
un sérieux dans la mise en oeuvre du
projet sur le retour des réfugiés
syriens et les conditions déjà été
réunies pour assurer leur retour
mesdames messieurs je veux souhaite tout
le succès dans ces deux conférences
j'espère que cette conférence qui va
encourager le retour des réfugiés
syriens et va constituer une étape
importante pour atténuer les problèmes
auxquels font face les filles qui ont
acquis et les réfugiés les qui ont
acquis les réfugiés les organisations
internationales à ne doivent pas
imposer des conditions inacceptables il
faut convaincre la plupart des réfugiés
que les conditions pour le retour ont
déjà été recueillies il faut créer une
possibilité pour la rétablir la paix et
la sueur et la réconciliation en syrie
cela doit constituer un signal pour
l'ensemble du monde que retour des
réfugiés syriens sera sécurisé aura lieu
dans les meilleurs délais merci
alors aux moyennes à masquer richard est
douce la baraudelle to be a rhabillé
souriez parole par lisbonne et chez moi
même j'ai mis trop ce qu'elle y fasse le
nom de son rival
bazas nos sols jean bodart guilbault
chat h à la catonnerie j'espère que
notre conférence sera le début d'une
nouvelle étape de reconstruction de
notre pays après neuf années de la
guerre et de la confrontation
je remercie la fédération de russie en
tant que partenaire stratégique de la
syrie dans la résolution de ce conflit
et merci pour l'organisation de cette
conférence une organisation de qualité
[Musique]
le problème de retour des réfugiés n'est
pas limitée par des aspects politiques
économiques et sociaux là nous avons un
volet humanitaire
en plus c'est un facteur important de la
mise en place de la confiance envers
toutes les parties intéressées
selon la surveiller qu'il arrête à 1000
de shanghaï mais là tu te souviens d'un
geek abbas à l'onu susan rice au bois
reymond ya des batteries à ce que je
ferai moudjar de fond de musique favoris
des souliers jour et ne nous arrêtera t
in motion au nom de la suisse aux
monnaies mellal changer de horgues et
pillages mais younousse réseau nas
madomé souvient monde vendredi nespoli
petit gars assis c'est donc un gros
party jeunes de guinée à l'environnement
de l'aspect social des familles darracq
chiche veuille ou non chez desjardins
factor fini j'étais dans des troubles et
aventuria zone euro la route du bourg à
prendre le problème des réfugiés c'est
le résultat de la guerre qui a été
imposée au peuple syrien et qui a duré
plus de dix ans le nombre de combattants
qui ont été soutenus par certains pays
ont à mener à une effusion de sang et à
la destruction du pays
aujourd'hui selon la statistique des
nations unies cette crise a obligé 5000
et 5 millions par dont 6000 de personnes
à fuir leur pays et vivre dans des camps
de réfugiés
en outre la statistique officielle des
nations unies donne le chiffre de 6
millions six cent mille personnes qui
sont des personnes déplacées à
l'intérieur du pays la plupart de ces
réfugiés vivent dans des conditions
difficiles dans par exemple
le camp d'al rockman financés par des
groupes terroristes et les pays comme
les etats-unis il
ils empêchent le retour de ces gens en
syrie à présent compte tenu de cette
tendance positive dans la libération du
territoire des terroristes et la
réduction d'intensité des combats la
solution des problèmes qui sont liés au
retour des réfugiés est vraiment
nécessaire
mais ce n'est pas le moment de penser
aux dividendes politiques
[Musique]
malheureusement nous constatons que
certains pays qui ont essuyé une défaite
en syrie en occupant
leur territoire et en soutenant les
terroristes en humiliant le peuple
syrien
en utilisant les instruments politiques
et économiques de pression l'adoption de
l'administration américaine de la loi de
césar qui vise la l'oppression du peuple
syrien
la politique des interdictions et des
sanctions c'est pas une politique
humanitaire c'est un échec
la république islamique d'iran continue
de participer à la solution de la crise
politique et est de nos peuples syrien a
mis à combattre le terrorisme
cela a donné des résultats positifs dans
la désescalade en syrie le déminage du
territoire grâce au format d'astana et
nos sommes certains que la série va
réussir
restaurer son pays et à créer des
conditions de retour des réfugiés
[Musique]
la république islamique d'iran continue
à participer à la résolution politique
de la crise syrienne
nos estimons que la communauté
internationale devrait être unis dans la
guerre contre le terrorisme participer
au format d'astana également puisque
c'est la seule voie politique qui est
possible pour restaurer l'infrastructure
syrienne ce qui est très important c'est
pourquoi la communauté internationale
devrait se tenir tous ses processus
politique
le retour sécurisé des réfugiés syriens
c'est le sujet qui est se levait à tous
les niveaux y compris dans le délicat
déclaration d'astana du 1er juillet de
cette année
j'ai acheté un élément innovatie sont
certains que la communauté
internationale devrait garantir réunir
toutes les conditions nécessaires pour
le retour des réfugiés et la
restauration de la vie normale en
augmentant l'aide fournie à siri et si
que en participant à la restauration et
au développement de l'infrastructure en
syrie dans ce contexte la république
islamique d'iran joue un rôle très
important pour améliorer la condition
économique de la syrie et ayant adopté
toute une série de mesures bol pour les
stores est restaurée l'infrastructure la
médecine
le système d'éducation le logement le
système énergétique est les
télécommunications et nos continuons à
prendre ces mesures
aujourd'hui même le nombre pays en se
basant sur des intérêts politiques
dresser des obstacles au lieu de
participer à cette conférence mais elle
les autorités de la république islamique
d'iran voient la nécessité de participer
à cette conférence puisque le problème
de retour des réfugiés syriens c'est un
problème très important et c'est
pourquoi la communauté internationale
devrait se tenir tous ses processus
[Musique]
la restauration de l'infrastructure a un
impact direct sur la solution du
problème du retour des réfugiés
la république islamique d'iran propose
de créer un fonds international pour
restaurer l infrastructure syrienne les
hostilités ont pris fin il ya deux ans
et maintenant le peuple seria a besoin
de la paix et de la stabilité qui ne
sont pas possibles sans le respect du de
la souveraineté et de la coopération
internationale je vous remercie
monsieur le vice ministre monsieur le
représentant du président russe vladimir
poutine
monsieur alexandre la frontière
mesdames et messieurs les ministres
mesdames et messieurs les ambassadeurs
je vous salue dans cette ville glorieuse
de damas
aujourd'hui nous sommes revenus nous
nous sommes réunis pour dire qu'il y à
la souffrance de notre peuple
neuf ans de guerre ont passé suite à
cette guerre des millions de nos
compatriotes ont fui leur pays
et cette conférence organisée à
l'initiative de la fédération de russie
vise le retour de ces gens nous avons
déjà commencé à surmonter cette crise
humanitaire
cette conférence devrait garantir le
retour sécurisé leur tour descend des
réfugiés dans leur propre maison
cette conférence est organisée à
l'initiative de la russie qui est une
force puissante et qui est le garant qui
est capable d'aider les réfugiés à
revenir
depuis cette crise mon pays le liban a
accueilli un grand nombre de réfugiés
syriens
c'est effectivement un nombre énorme
compte tenu du territoire de notre petit
pays
actuellement c'est environ un tiers de
la population libanaise
mais pour eux le liban n'est pas un pays
étranger mais nous vivons dans des
conditions de la crise financière et
économique et de la communauté
multiconfessionnel nous traversons
également la crise et de lakovic 19
l'explosion dans le port de beyrouth a
aggravé cette crise économique bien sûr
et aujourd'hui on peut dire que plus de
60% de libanais et plus de 80% de
réfugiés syriens vivent au dessous du
seuil de pauvreté
les dépenses directes et indirectes
au cours de ces neuf ans ont constitué
plus de 40 millions de dollars ce qui a
aggravé le problème est l'état des
réfugiés a créé des difficultés dans la
création d emplois mais pour surmonter
ces difficultés
le liban a besoin du soutien de la
communauté internationale
cette aide devrait être beaucoup plus
importante
pour le moment nous avons reçu environ
vivent à gueuler soixante dix huit
milliards de dollars conformément à la
constitution libanaise qui interdisent
la naturalisation des réfugiés et en
partant des internationaux du liban
nous devons permettre aux réfugiés de
revenir
en syrie conformément aux nations unies
plus de 80% de réfugiés voudrais revenir
en syrie mais il est important de
coordonner nos efforts dans le cadre de
la coopération internationale et le
gouvernement libanais est d'accord avec
le plan national qui vise le retour
sécurisé et digne des réfugiés dieu 14
juillet 2020 sous contrôle du ministre
des affaires étrangères qui répondent à
ces défis de la crise humanitaire à ce
plan de retour des réfugiés
adopté par le gouvernement libanais est
conforme à toutes les normes du droit
international et aux principes du retour
volontaire des réfugiés et maintient le
droit du retour digne et décent de
réfugiés dans leurs maisons
ce plan est basé sur la simplification
et faciliter les conditions du retour
avec le soutien de la communauté
internationale
la russie nous soutient dans le cadre de
la réalisation de ce plan depuis et le
début de cette crise le liban a fourni
des efforts importants pour faire
revenir les réfugiés sans prendre en
compte des décisions politiques le
retour des réfugiés palestiniens est un
exemple éclatant des difficultés de ce
processus le retour des réfugiés syriens
a débuté en 2018
quand nous avons réuni des conditions de
sécurité en syrie
ces personnes ont fui la syrie suite à
la guerre et non pas suite à des
problèmes politiques les services
libanais de sécurité et leurs collègues
et syriens travaillent ensemble avec les
institutions onusiennes le flux de
réfugiés a été réduit maintenant suite à
la pandémie de lakovic 19 les réfugiés
rencontre maintenant des difficultés en
traversant la frontière mais en même
temps la syrie a besoin de la main
d'oeuvre pour restaurer le pays tous les
séries tout tous les syriens vont
travailler sur la restauration de leur
propre pays comme l'ont fait les
libanais après la guerre civile dans
notre pays encore une fois merci au
gouvernement syrien merci à la
fédération de russie qui fournissent des
efforts dans la lutte contre les forces
du mal et les forces du terrorisme qui
soutiennent le pluralisme et qui
garantissent leur tour
sécuriser et digne des réfugiés syriens
ce qui va stabiliser la situation dans
notre région permettez moi également de
remercier la république arabe syrienne
les autorités syriennes et le peuple
syrien pour l'organisation de cette
conférence nous voyons que la société
syrienne est capable de le faire et nous
espérons que cette conférence va
contribuer à ce travail pratique sur le
terrain pour que les réfugiés syrienne
seria reviennent en syrie et recommence
une vie normale merci
pour le moment si le procédé à des
essais de nicolas durand estime à pour
l'asie et à ses amis est belle et rennes
linaro estime à dori en jaune souriait
aux guérillas et sourire profil assez
matsuri huayra qui ça allait mais les
frci noailles artifices trou est fait le
trafic matière au président menace avait
rétabli is me gêne sinatra danielle
jeanne de souris pénétre à azali steam a
envie de dire ligue 1
aussi les jours où 18 films jazz elle
estime à wetteren l'iliade matra djet
telegraph
oui je vous dirais al-jaber moffatt
ratatouille là mais agile el mostrador
dames la chine a souri et dette est trop
bête fille sourit hélène aux rings à des
cabinets souris roccat l'asie les
tomates le problème des réfugiés est un
problème également pour les pays voisins
et la décision qui a été prise est très
important pour résoudre le problème des
réfugiés
pour le retour en syrie et cela
correspond aux intérêts de l'ensemble
des pays de la région et de la
communauté internationale
le conseiller du président de la chine a
déjà dit que les réfugiés ne sont pas
les immigrés mais ils se trouvent
partout dans le monde
il faut assurer leur retour et retables
ira leur logement le retour des réfugiés
sériant c'est un problème compliqué qui
est aggravée par de nombreux facteurs il
faut créer les conditions de sécurité et
résoudre l'ensemble des problèmes pour
résoudre le problème des réfugiés tout
d'abord il faut créer les conditions
politiques la question syrienne en soit
c'est une question politique est la
solution politique est la seule solution
réelle
ce faisant elle est nécessaire de
respecter la souveraineté l'indépendance
et l'intégrité territoriale de la syrie
il est également important de respecter
le fait que ce processus doit à ce
dernier
cela dit réjean ce des syriens il faut
examiner l'ensemble des activités dans
le cadre de ce dialogue
compte tenu des très particulier de ce
puits et la syrie les émeutes en syrie
continue depuis déjà neuf ans et bien
sûr il y aura de nouveaux conflits entre
l'opposition le gouvernement mais nous
espérons que l'ensemble des parties sont
intéressées à
à continuer le dialogue et respecter le
bon sens dans le cadre des négociations
nous espérons que le soutien des nations
unies et dieu représentant spécial
messieurs peterson seront harmonisés le
deuxième chose c'est l'amélioration du
climat politique
le retour des réfugiés nécessite le
rétablissement de l'infrastructure
détruit par la guerre
certains pays imposent les actions
illégitime unilatérale sur la série ils
négligent les besoins du peuple et
souriant surtout dans les conditions de
la propagation de la nouvelle infection
le coût 8 19
la prise des mesures réelles et mieux
que les promesses qui sont vides et il
est nécessaire de rétablir à le pays
nous devons ensemble travailler sur les
plans d'action pour améliorer le niveau
de vie des citoyens et active ise
l'économie compte tenu des besoins des
citoyens syriens
il faut donner un élan au rétablissement
de l'état en prenant des mesures claires
troisième chose pour éliminer le
terrorisme en syrie
il faut également prendre certaines
mesures car c'est important pour le
retour des réfugiés
il est difficile de rétablir la paix
sans éliminer le terrorisme la
communauté internationale doit réunir
ses efforts pour éliminer l'ensemble des
groupes terroristes a reconnu comme tel
par le conseil de sécurité sans de quoi
deux mesures on ne peut pas s'arrêter
sur cette voie de lutte contre le
terrorisme il faut lutter contre le
terrorisme jusqu'à la fin pour prévenir
sa nouvelle apparition sur le sol syrien
il faut à bloquer les sources de
financement de recrutement de nouveaux
terroristes il faut combattre contre
ceux qui emploient les diots logis
terroristes et essayer de déstabiliser
la situation et contrôler l'esprit des
gens comme ça nous pouvons détruire
éliminer le terrorisme et rétablir la
sécurité et la stabilité en syrie
mesdames messieurs
la chine doit soutenir fermement le
rétablissement de la souveraineté de
l'intégrité territoriale
nous avons proposé plusieurs initiatives
pour soutenir les organisations les
opérations internationales humanitaires
la chine est intéressée d'un le retour
des réfugiés syriens
nous avons versé plus de 130 millions de
dollars à la syrie via les mécanismes
internationaux et bilatéraux face au co
vite 19 les entreprises et les citoyens
chinois ont envoyé
les deux militaires en syrie pour lutter
contre le coc vide nos experts
spécialistes ont partagé leurs
expériences de lutte contre le coc u19
nous allons poursuivre notre soutien et
déployer nos efforts pour résoudre le
problème syrien dans le meilleur délai
et afin de parvenir à une paix durable
en syrie merci
mais chez mon alim
mesdames et messieurs au nom de la
fédération de russie et en mon nom
personnel je voudrais vous saluer à
cette ouverture de la conférence à damas
pour moi c'est un grand honneur de
prendre la parole à cet événement aussi
important à l'échelle internationale la
nécessité de tenir ce forum a pour la
série et pour tous les pays de la région
qui accueille un grand nombre de
réfugiés est due à la nécessité de la
coordination des efforts de toutes les
parties intéressées dans la création des
conditions pour le retour des réfugiés
en syrie
je suis certain que le programme de
cette conférence et la liste des
participants vont permettre de procéder
à des discussions et de d'aborder toute
la panoplie de questions qui nécessitent
des solutions intégrées je vois dans
cette salle le coordinateur des sections
des nations unies en syrie monsieur
réseau qui représente toutes les
structures onusiennes qui coopèrent avec
le gouvernement ainsi rien le centre
russe pour la réconciliation des parties
est en contact avec monsieur réseau et
ses collègues
cette conférence va parler des grandes
options de la coopération entre le
gouvernement syrien et les nations unies
pour le travail efficace de des
structures onusiennes sur le territoire
syrian je salue également monsieur
philippe ce père qui représente la croix
rouge qui
continue son travail sur le territoire
syria de cet autre tribune je voudrais
souligner que notre pays la russie est
sincère a souhaité la paix en syrie sur
tout le territoire de la république
arabe syrienne et le retour des réfugiés
qui ont fui le pays suite à des actions
terroristes le peuple russe connaît très
bien ce que c'est la guerre
et quels sont les souffrances causées
par la guerre cette année la fédération
de russie à commémorer le 70e
anniversaire de la victoire du peuple
soviétique du nazisme qui a emporté 28
millions de vies des centaines de
militants fo ont été anéanties par les
nazis en 1941 46 personnes sont partis
au front dans mon propre village est et
de nombreux ne sont pas revenus en 1944
le l'oncle mon oncle mikhail mise en
scène a péri j'ai hérité son prénom
et c'est pourquoi je voudrais dire que
nous comprenons très bien la nécessité
de retour de la paix et du retour des
réfugiés en syrie les réer les russes et
disait que la mauvaise paix une paix
mauvaise c'est mieux que c'est qu'une
guerre de toute façon c'est pourquoi les
souffrances eux doivent être arrêtés sur
le sol syrien en russie
nous comptons plus de 190 ethnie c'est
un pays multiconfessionnel et même les
noms de nos deux pays se rassemblent en
arabe et en russie le 4 novembre nous
avons célébré la journée de l'unité
nationale porno c'est une fête très
importante qui célèbre légalité et
l'union de tous les peuples et toutes
les ethnies sur le sol russe no espérons
que le peuple syrien va retrouver la
paix la paix qui étaient perturbés par
des groupes terroristes
je voudrais citer les paroles du
président russe vladimir poutine a
adressé aux russes le 4 novembre
il faut comprendre que dans le monde
soper des grands changements et les
valeurs traditionnelles font face à des
défis les questions sensibles des
relations interconfessionnelles
deviennent parfois l'objet de
spéculations des jeux politiques et les
extrémistes utilisent ce fait en
utilisant la haine et les hostilités les
événements en france et en autriche
en témoigne ce sont des actes
terroristes qui montre qu' il n'y a pas
d'unité dans cette lutte contre le
terrorisme les pays deviennent en proie
des terroristes et les simples gens
souffrent dans ce contexte cette
conférence revêt une importance encore
encore plus grand de tous ceux qui
comprennent à quel point cela est
important ont été invités à cette
conférence il s'agit bien sûr d'abord
des pays qui accueillent des réfugiés
nous savons que de nombreux pays ont
souhaité
à participer à cette conférence mais
malheureusement les autorités de ces
pays n'ont pas su surmonter cette
pression exercée par certains pays
occidentaux et nous savons qu'il y avait
même des instructions aux participants
potentiels à cette conférence à
boycotter cette conférence est et
pourtant cette conférence mais est
consacrée aux problèmes humanitaires
nous avons proposé aux états unis
d'amérique a participé à participer à
l'arrêt de la zone de thibaud
d'occupation la région des eaux sur le
territoire syrien et la résolution du
problème du camp rock band mais
malheureusement les autorités
américaines n'ont pas répondu à cette
invitation et les réfugiés continuent à
vivre dans des conditions de la famine
et du froid
mais nous sommes certains que cette
conférence donnera un nouveau départ
aujourd'hui et demain nous allons parler
et des zones d'installation des réfugiés
qui sont revenus et le gouvernement
syrien y travaillent
suite à ce forum
la communauté internationale va être
informé sur la situation réelle en jury
en syrie sur les problèmes qui sont en
place et sur le travail de restauration
qui est réalisé par le gouvernement
syrien
nous espérons que cette conférence sera
très importante pour ceux qui souhaitent
participer à notre travail conjoint mais
qu'ils ont
refuser à participer en cédant à la
pression de certains pays
mais je souligne que heureux du retour
des réfugiés est conforme pleinement aux
principes des nations unies ce principe
de retours volontaires le principe de la
garantie des conditions de retour à ce
sont les priorités de l'activité du
gouvernement syrien
le l'état-major interministériel de
coordination qui a été créée en 2018
sur décision du président syrien y
contribuer merci au président syrien
docteur bachar el-assad sur décision du
président russe
nous avons créé le l'état-major russe
c'est l'état major inter ministérielle
de coordination qui attire l'attention
de la communauté internationale sur le
problème
du retour des réfugiés et qui invite à
changer les approches dans ce travail en
se tenant le peuple syrien
les ministères russes il travaille avec
toutes les institutions et les autorités
syriennes noël ils ont des projets dans
l'éducation la santé publique
l'exploitation des ressources naturelles
le logement la coopération technique et
scientifique
nous avons créé une centre de formation
sur le sol syrien qui a formé plus d'une
centaine de professeurs de la langue
russe dans des universités syriennes
il y à des professeurs qui ont été
fermées par ce centre et plus d'un
millier de d'étudiants syriens sont
formés dans des universités russes
nous avons augmenté les côtes cottard de
formation des étudiants sérieux dans les
universités russes ses objectifs
humanitaires concerne également la
restauration des réseaux électriques des
sites de culte
la russie a débloqué pour cela plus d'un
milliard de dollars nous avons signé un
milliard un mémorandum qui permet de
débloquer 20 millions de dollars pour
l'aide humanitaire entre les ministères
surya et russes ont été signés plus de
neuf accords et durant cette conférence
nous allons encore
signé quatre accords ce qui va ouvrir
les perspectives du développement des
relations gagnant gagnant sur tous les
niveaux et sur tous les terrains pour
garantir le retour des réfugiés
nous avons tenu 30 une réunion commune
et des états-majors de coordination pour
garantir le retour des réfugiés dans le
travail de deux réunions les
représentants des nations unies ont
participé et ce qui est très important
c'est un major de coordination c'est une
source d'une information véridique sur
la situation en place en syrie la
communauté internationale en est informé
nos publions cette information en forme
de bulletin d'information dans le cadre
de ces c'est un major anneaux
n'écoperont copco paieront également
avec les autorités du liban et de la
jordanie
nous avons réussi à ouvrir les
checkpoints pour le passage des réfugiés
et depuis le territoire de ces pays
le grand nombre de réfugiés sont revenus
je voudrais également les des réfugiés
syriens en turquie nous attendons le
retour de 3,5 millions de réfugiés
mais pour cela nous avons besoin de
nouvelles initiatives
mesdames et messieurs bien sûr il ya
tout un nombre de problèmes qui ne sont
pas encore résolus mais nous avons
besoin du soutien des autorités
syriennes et nos estimons que parmi les
obstacles qui se dressent sur la voie de
retour des réfugiés
on peut citer d'abord un c'est la
présence illégale des militaires
étrangers sur le sol syrien qui violent
la souveraineté de la syrie dans toutes
les régions qui ne sont pas sous
contrôle des autorités syriennes
il y à une situation difficile
prenons par exemple la base américaine
qui couvre l'activité terroriste des
groupes terroristes
ces combattants et coiffe le camp de
réfugiés intitulée alles roggeman ou
soro reste encore à plus de 4 ou 1000
personnes les américains utilisent cette
situation pour l'acheminement d'une aide
soit disant humanitaires qui sont
destinés finalement au combattant dans
d'autres
quand la situation est encore plus
difficile des milliers de gens souffrent
des conditions inhumaines
plus de la moitié de ces gens ce sont
des enfants des femmes qui n'ont pas la
possibilité d'aller à l'école et qui
sont enrôlés dans les principes de
l'extrémisme et qui sont des membres
potentiels des groupements terroristes
dans ces conditions la fédération de
russie par la différence de certains
pays travaillent sur le retour des
en russie des des enfants des citoyens
syriens le travail
le groupe de travail dirigé par madame
cossenet de sova a réussi à accueillir
en réussissant deux enfants et encore
quelques enfants attendent leur venue en
russie
mais et c'est un roulement des jeunes
dans des groupements terroristes
continuent les réfugiés qui se trouvent
dans des camps de réfugiés sont
contrôlées par des groupes terroristes
depuis août
ils ont recruté une trentaine de
personnes et ce qui soulagerait sous la
direction des moniteurs américains sont
formés dans ces camps ceux qui profitent
de cette situation devrait quand même
être plus sage puisque le problème arabe
dit ce qui sème le vent qu est la
tempête
il s'agit aussi du pillage des
ressources naturelles qui appartiennent
au peuple syrien et qui alimentent les
groupes terroristes ce qui crée une
situation de tension c'est aussi est la
restriction et les barrières sur la
livraison de ressources qui sont
nécessaires en syrie mais ces ressources
sont nécessaires pour le pays
à tandis que les pays occidentaux
continuent à investir dans des activités
terroristes
malgré les problèmes avec les migrants
en europe les pays occidentaux
continuent à financer les groupes
terroristes
nos condamnant les sanctions la
politique des sanctions qui créent des
obstacles sur la restauration et prive
les syria de la vie décente
il est très difficile de pallier à des
difficultés économiques dans ces
situations c'est aussi la campagne des
faits qui news ce sont des informations
un torse qui embrouille les esprits des
réfugiés selon nos estimations plus d'un
million trois cent mille syrien qui
vivent dans ce quinze pays étrangers au
saut était de revenir en syrie mais ils
ont peur parce que il y à une pression
des médias désintox et il y à des
accusations du gouvernement syrien
dans la violation des droits de l'homme
les ennemis des autorités syriennes
continuent à faire dresser des obstacles
sur dans la voie du processus politique
dans important dans la résolution
onusienne
22 54 il est clairement formulé que
c'est le droit interne du pays de la
république arabe syrienne
nous avons également créé l'organisme
suite au forum de sotchi en 2018 qui
devrait relancer le processus
conventionnels la diffusion de la copie
de 19 et pose aussi un grand problème au
service de la santé publique
en syrie ils ont vraiment besoin du
soutien et de l'aide internationale
alors pour faire revenir les personnes
réfugiées et déplacées il faut d'abord à
toutes les parties intéressées respecter
le droit international les principes des
nations unies et garantir les courts
délais du transfert des dettes des
droits de contrôle des régions occupées
aux autorités syriennes liquider les
camps de réfugiés illégaux et faire
revenir ces personnes dans leur propre
maison
il faut restaurer la pleine souveraineté
et l'intégrité territoriale de la syrie
ce qui va permettre à garantir le retour
des simples syrien qui vont travailler
sur la restauration du pays
il faut arrêter la politique de
sanctions il faut il faut faire revenir
l'argent qui appartient au peuple syrien
et il faut garantir la restauration de
l'infrastructure qui est nécessaire pour
le retour des personnes réfugiées et
pour l'aide humanitaire
il est économiquement raisonnable
d'investir des ressources qui pourraient
permettre aux réfugiés de revenir le
gouvernement syrien garantie ce retour
sécurisé et digne aux personnes
réfugiées il faut arrêter là discret
tease il faut arrêter à discréditer les
autorités syriennes
il faut arrêter cette propagande
destructive qui embrouille les espèces
les esprits de réfugiés il faut arrêtez
de politiser ce processus de retour et
se conformer aux principes des nations
unies il faut soutenir le gouvernement
sérieux dans la lutte contre la copie de
et là le rétablissement du système de
santé publique
la russie a acheminé plus de 60 e 18
tonnes d aide humanitaire y compris des
médicaments pour lutter contre la
pandémie
c'est toute la bande et panoplie de des
questions économiques et sociales pour
recréer des conditions de retour dans
leur propre maison
nos estimons que ce forum deviendra un
outil qui va réunir toutes les forces et
va permettre le retour des réfugiés dans
le pays qui mérite son nom de berceau de
civilisations comme le problème est que
comme le proverbe russe dit là où vous
êtes né vous devrait vivre et il ya
aussi un proverbe arabe le talent que tu
possèdes est nécessaire pour ton propre
pays
et je voudrais vous montrer en terminant
des dessins d'enfants que j'ai ce sont
des dessins syrien enfants syriens à
l'âge de quatre cinq six ans les
représentants russes ont visité les
camps de réfugiés sur le territoire du
liban ils ont posé des questions très
simples aux enfants et ils ont demandé
aux enfants de dessiner leur propre vie
qu'est ce qu'ils aiment qu'est ce qu'il
n'aime pas et quelles sont les
difficultés et se ressemblent
la plupart d'enfants n'aime pas la
guerre la guerre qui est porteuse de
malheurs et de l'armée mais ce qu'il
aime
à l'instar de n'importe quel enfant
ils veulent la paix le ciel le bonheur
avec leurs propres familles avec leurs
parents quant au regard de cils dessins
des enfants
tu comprends que nous sommes obligés de
faire tout notre possible pour que ces
espoirs ne soient pas vains veine
j'espère que notre conférence va
contribuer à assainir l'économie de la
syrie et continuer dans cette voie
la levée des barrières la levée des
sanctions le retour des réfugiés
je remercie personnellement le docteur
bachar el assad le président syrien pour
cette idée d'organisation de cette
conférence internationale je remercie
les autorités syriennes
le peuple syrien pour
le travail de préparation de notre forum
et je remercie également tous les
participants pour votre attention je
vous remercie
c'est à 312 chocolat rôle comme à des
jeux sadiques tae hwan a forgé sa
liberté d'arcade à la bagarre n'est-on
pas marina merci la conférence est finie
[Musique]